ester I'm in so much trouble what
happened Sam been either the number
eater
ate all my numbers on my perfect number
grid ha ha ha ha ha
those are some good numbers huh well I
better get out of here before I get into
some trouble Ben
Esther what do I do that's our curse
I've written work together to find the
missing numbers actually I think our
friends who are watching the video can
help us with it so our friend go ahead
and pause the video
I'll see if you can figure out what a
missing numbers okay I'm assuming our
friends have given a go at it
so how would you think about this Esther
that's soon Oh Rama little I can use the
numbers that are per for the missing
number to help us figure this out so
that's uh Africa from four five six that
makes sense
what about this one huh what's uh what's
a written figure out what would come
after the number thirty hmm maybe we
should get our friends to think about it
first come on yeah so I'm assuming they
try so how do you think about it what
number comes after thirteen what soon
thirteen fourteen and that works out
because then fourteen is the number that
comes before fifteen the vast world I
see now look at this this is all the way
out here huh how are you going to figure
this one out Esther hmm what's uh maybe
I can look at the numbers that come
after the missing number so if we have
37 and 38 I'm 39
I think 36 comes before a 37 oh that
makes a lot of sense and what about this
one that's right below it
okay what's ooh I think I'm gonna count
in a different road I was a girl
from the top to the bottom Wow how are
you going to do that
let's see I'll start with number six my
girl down to 16
girl down to 26 go down to 36 I think I
see a pattern here
all of these numbers have a 6 exact
route so I think if we're in the missing
number that's gonna be 46 oh I see and
that makes sense because here this was
where 26 then 36 here were in the 40s so
it's going to be 46 that's really cool
now what about these three down here
maybe our friends can pause first and
see if they can figure it out sounds
good
okay how would I tackle this Esther
Watson but there are three missing
numbers on an arrow so let's look at the
numbers before I after so we have
everyone editor over 384 well that makes
sense because we're in the 80s and so
just like we have one two three four now
it's 81 82 83 84 exact Road and I know
the number that is next to it for is 85
and we know that because five comes
after four so 85 comes after 84 I don't
know Wow and this would be 86 very
exciting very fun thank you
oh no it's it's Benny to the number
eater again Oh more numbers to munch on
I'm getting hungry